listo ahora si empezamos oficialmente la clase y les voy a colocar lo siguiente
yo creo que nadie más ventral se que de nuevo mentico más para que les muestre el sistemito
lo que hiciera lo primero quisiera saber de ustedes cuál es la versión que tienen de sus
sistemas operativos y también ahorita os voy a mostrar cómo tienen que calcularlo es y cómo
tienen que mostrarlo para que no tengan problemas listo y ahorita os voy a compartir el temario
también para que puedan observarlo ya ahora si
listo ahora si empezaremos
es el temario que les voy a mostrar
ya la integración en este caso de n8n a nivel más que todo de negocios y todo lo que tienen
que ver el ámbito tanto de transacciones automatización es todo aspecto es el siguiente
flujo ya nuestras clases van a dividir en las siguientes partes son actualmente por semana
vamos a pasar dos clases así que al mes tendríamos más o menos ocho clases en nuestros meses
tenemos 24 clases de las 24 clases vamos a pasar netamente en las 22 así legalmente y las
demás van a hacer presentaciones de sus prototipos ya este es el módulo 1 tenemos en este caso total
seis módulos de los cuales vamos a trabajar a nivel un poquito más avanzado para pero ojo no es una
clase de programación así que en ese aspecto no se preocupen listo pero si es que nos acaso algún
tiempo vamos a tratar de hacerlo quizás con ias y con sistemas integros en sus mismos computadoras
y trabajar con otras dependencias de inteligencia artificiales o como también ustedes le llaman
agentes ya así que en ese aspecto normal vamos a trabajar ya vamos a instalar la versión de n8n
la última vamos a trabajar con servidores de amazon web service o a bw s también la conocen
vamos a trabajar con xux y sistemas de chet tepe los voy a explicar todo eso en un nivel un poquito
más entendible ahorita es un poquito chino quizás para nosotros algunos puntos y vamos a trabajar
también con web hoots crawl manual triggers ser de cebásico whatsapp integración de whatsapp
integración de sus sistemas internos en fabricación de epis y también con consumos de
apis públicas también con consumos de apis internas y voy a tratar de enseñar cómo se va a manejar
más que todos los que son los sistemas de secuel pero no ligado a programación sino es más un
entorno de de aplicativo y que sea más interesante las clases para no agobiarles mucho en programación
y hay aquí en hecho en es es más dirigido a personas que no tienen conocimiento
básico ni avanzado en programación o sea tenemos que aprender de manera
sincrona sin tener sin tener que depender de algunos tipos de fraymos y así que ese aspecto
si tienen dudas preguntas amenazas durante la clase no hay problema traten de siempre preguntar
interrumpir porque es la única forma y veces de que todos podamos hacer compilar los proyectos
ya y ahorita me presento una vez que entre en todos esperamos unos un poquito más a los demás
integrantes ya ahora si me presento a por si acaso si es que desean
obtener procesos y sistemas muy avanzados en programación y en aplicaciones pueden
entrar mi git si vienen acá y colocan git es voy a pasar esto ahí tengo 12 positores uno
de los cuales tiene un montón de proyectos avanzados tiene arimas arima hay conexiones
avanzadas automatizaciones sistemas aplicativos también trabajamos con drones
sistemas de control avanzado también misiles de alcance directo de kibis desolios exponenciales
estandarizaciones hay todo ahí lo pueden descargar y también os voy a pasar un repositor
interno donde tenemos ahí algunos puntos ya bueno me presento soy doctor en ciencias espaciales
y también soy ingeniero informático y ahorita estoy haciendo más ingeniero espacial en la
universidad nacional autónoma de vexico en la unam y actualmente también tengo un maestría en
la universidad de oxford y cambridge de sistemas aeroespaciales y sistemas difusos y actualmente
también soy docente en la umsa en la unifrance en la uv en la emi en algunos instituciones más
actualmente tengo 300 libros escritos para sistemas de control avanzado y si quieren si tienen
dudas y interés en el campo es un poco más interesante es muy lío bueno aquí me presento
este es más o menos mi para que me conozcan y pues en base yo podemos trabajar en varios aspectos
no solamente automatización si tienen dudas en preguntas en cosas que no tiene que ver con
esta materia y con esta capacitación pues no hay problema listo así que en ese aspecto no hay
problema chico cos bueno yo les voy a tratar así y podemos trabajar un montón de sistemas avanzados
así que no hay problema en ese aspecto y ahora si empezaremos con la clase si tienen dudas
preguntas hasta ese nivel con gusto los responda ya ya listo como no hay preguntas como no hay dudas
vamos a empezar con sistemas aplicativos ya voy a abrir una en google en este caso les voy a mostrar
cómo trabajen en 8n cómo se trabaja con sistemas un poco más avanzados así que voy a tratar de
habilitar o no y listo abran una interfaz un navegador que navegador que ustedes deseen la clase las
clases van a ser recontrapácticas así que traten si o si de detener siempre su laptop o su computador
de escritoria al lado para no quedarse atrás ya así que empezaremos lo primero que voy a tratar de
explicar es algo de teoría básica para no irme directamente al punto y no desfasar es un poquito
ustedes así que en base eso voy a tratar de trabajar con eso listo así que vamos a colocar acá
x calibrado listo vamos a colocar listo voy a habilitar nuevo listo
listo
de menco hecho lo voy a borrar todo esto que las pasadas así que
ya ahora sí entaremos en contexto ya bueno excálida pueden utilizarlo para ser igual a algunas
diapositivas para hacer entornos de de explicación más rápida y profunda es bastante didáctico
esta esta aplicación ya que pasó ricardo por esto consulta
se tienen preguntas no dudan en decirlo ya no hay problema chico
ya valería alición cual esto consulta
y en el nuevo en las noches
y también creo que una plataforma interactiva todas las herramientas y elementos lo va a compartir al
final de la clase se automáticamente debe ser a subir en un en un repositorio yo lo voy a trabajar
netamente con una aplicación interna o también lo vamos a trabajar con
con claro también ya así que en ese perspective no hay problema se va a también pasar tanto en
el sistema como en la plataforma de claro y ambos tanto la grabación y todo así si se está grabando
disto no te preocupes está grabando así que no se preocupen listo lo voy a grabar en zoom
chicos porque si lo graban otros son es bien pesado cuando usted trabaja con obese estudio
de más es muy pesado y van a tener problemas y veces en solamente con pilar y demás ya así que
voy a trabajar si listo empezaremos entonces la clase automatización vaya a colocar acá y me van a
tratar de entender si tienen dudas preguntas todo no hay problema en hacerlo ya así que en
ese aspecto normal y a cuando vamos a manejar automatización no solamente vamos a manejar el
término de automatización el término de automatización no solamente repercute en ámbitos de
que tenemos que hacer aplicaciones donde todo se nos haga la idea o la inteligencia artificial si se
puede si pero generalmente cuando hacemos automatización requiere dos puntos fundamentales uno
que trabajemos en la nube como ya sabemos la mayoría de nosotros o también que podamos trabajar de
manera local hay dos diferencias yo lo voy a hacer en ambos casos voy a trabajar en tres
tipos de sistemas voy a trabajar con los que van a manejar docker van a trabajar con los que van
a manejar con sistemas mucho más básicos internos en su sistema y voy a trabajar también con datos
en la nube ya y al trabajar con datos en la nube no solamente estoy diciendo que vamos a trabajar
todo el sistema sincronizado con el internet trabajar en la nube significa que también nosotros
podemos trabajar de manera asincrona y sincrona a qué me refiero con eso que cuando nosotros procesamos
datos los datos deberían de por ejemplo un ejemplo a ver básico digamos yo estoy en la calle estoy
viajando a una provincia y en la provincia el sistema se pierda esa no hay señal pero sé que los datos
de mis mensajes de se de whatsapp ongamos como ejemplo están ingresando a mi celular pero se
ha dado cuenta que cuando ustedes entran en señal le llega un montón de mensajes es por eso se
llama esos plataformas sincronas y plataformas asincronas se compatibilizan y entran en redundancia
mutua para darles a ustedes la información que ya se ha guardado en la nube es lo mismo que se hace
también automatizaciones pero esto ya requiere un poquito de más capacidad de la computadora así
es que van a trabajar de manera local ahora al hacerlo de manera local no solamente nosotros
trabajamos en una computadora o se podemos trabajar con redes y al momento de hacer redes estos
sistemas van creciendo y van creciendo y podemos crear plataformas sumamente inmensas sin depender
del internet pero eso ya va a ser mucho depende de ustedes si quieren aplicar este sin nivel pero
voy a tratar de enseñarles hasta ese nivel hasta que hagamos sistemas artificiales en
en ciudades contemporáneas lo dice o ciudades en este caso de agentes de ida pero eso ya va a ser
mucho de la capacidad de sus computadoras para ver si soportan si no os voy a tratar de trabajar lo
más básico igual nos avanza todos sus sistemas y nos alcanza un poco más de tiempo pues voy a
trabajar en un habitoso ya al momento de trabajar vuelvas a repetir es con la nube está mucho
tomamos trabajando de manera sin croná sin croná
listo y también se llama de manera en bebida
y cuando trabajamos es un sistema se automatizados y vamos a trabajar de manera legal ahora
otra manera de trabajar de con automotor es directamente trabajar de manera local y para
trabajar de manera local hay dos campos grandes uno podemos trabajar con no gs y otro podemos
trabajarlo con docker y algunos con docker y otros con no gs o sea no de gs eso se trabaja en
ambientes locales ahora cuando trabajamos de manera híbrida ahorita os voy a mostrar eso de un
cachito estoy besas y ahora si ahí y ahora acá por ejemplo vamos a trabajar de manera línea
los estos ya se llaman híbridos cuando trabajamos en el hecho de manera híbrida mezclamos tanto el
nube o local ahí es donde entran los agentes y agentes de lla vamos a colocar bien miscubos
agentes de lla
listo entonces lo primero que vamos a hacer hoy día es instalar
ya las instalaciones van a tardar hay veces yo voy a empezar de manera local
es lo primero que los voy a enseñar de ahí vamos a pasar a los demás porque lo demás es
casi se aplica lo mismo solamente que en el otro se paga y en el otro ya y en base a eso vamos a
trabajar de dos maneras cuando trabaje de manera local si vamos a trabajar con sistemas más avanzados
podemos trabajar con oyama podemos trabajar con clouds o podemos trabajar con open codes
la ocult sería en ese caso yo generalmente estoy más acostumbrado a trabajar con oyama y con algunos
agentes internos de cloud pero mucho va a depender de cómo están trabajando ustedes o que yas
utilizan la mayoría de ustedes debe utilizar el famoso chat y pt o chat y pt otros deben utilizar
cloud otros deben utilizar yemina y otros de la de psique bueno tiene ventajas y desventajas cada
uno por ejemplo de psique me sirva a mí más para codificación y cloud también pero yas como
yemina y más va a ser para sistemas de investigación avanzada en el nivel científico digamos pero
también hay otros que son variables o rock que también se trabaja de manera mucho más investigativa
así que hay dependencias y así que en base a eso que manejan ustedes chicos a modo que me adecuaste
es que tipo de yas están manejando cuál es su día más como ya ve y marc cual es tuya más
más confiable
pueden hablar nomás no hay problema o daniel cueto igual
a buenas que tal buenas en mi caso la idea que más utilizo es en este caso códex
junto con yemina y chas pt y open cloud con olama pero todo lo que es cloud no lo utilizo
debido a que tiene muy limitado sus tokens exacto los skills también exacto de veces es limitantes
si lo vamos a utilizar en los aspectos ya ahora quisiera haceros la siguiente pregunta levanten la
mano y en ese ya dominan la programación avanzada porque esta clase es más para más dedicado a
personas y en este caso negocios donde casi no vamos a tocar programación pero quisiera saber
cuántas personas dominan la programación y dominan el manejo de yas o interfaces avanzadas
pueden levantar la mano
y a uno y en más dos
a lo que sabía dos personas según me comunicaron ya siguiente pregunta quienes no saben nada
cero así todo cero cero
para que vaya su ritmo sean sincer de dos personas los tres
y ya
ya tres los demás entonces de los terren intermedio ya porque me refiero esto porque voy a avanzar
en base a ellos ya si ustedes quieren un poquito más no hay problema me pueden preguntar y con
gusto les responde pero había tratado de avanzar desde cero absolutamente si como si no
supiéramos nada de yas nada de programación absolutamente nada de nada ya para que todos
vayamos en el mismo camino ya ahora sí les presentaré lo siguiente ya
vamos a manejar en este caso doctor así que vayense a tocar
ya y vaya a abrir otro más van a abrir lo que es en este caso no yas así van a coca no de jota
esa y les va a aparecer esto ya los voy a mandar el link a la a la mensajería de de mit
entre en ahí y hasta ya les he enviado y vayan a vamos a descartar lo siguiente
yo no ten este caso su antecesor era ya pero sé que quizás la mayoría no conoce estos aspectos
de programación pero no actualmente me ofrecen trabajos como interfaces tanto de bacán como
tanto de front a que más refiero como front y bacán bacán lo podemos hacer un ejemplo interesante
que cuando ustedes han construido su casa al principio solamente que hacen el cimiento los
machones o sea todos un esqueleto eso para mí es un bacán pero cuando se colocamos ladrillo le
colocamos calamina le pintamos le colocamos montón de cosas para que se ve estético eso se llama
front entonces no está netamente destinado a trabajar con como bacán y se le puede manipular
también como front ya o sea esas dos cosas pero en este caso yo no me voy a ir al ámbito de la
programación me voy al ámbito de que esto es como el autito que me va a llevar a mí hacer todo el
problemario y toda la secuencia que vamos a codificarlo de manera como si no supiéramos absolutamente
nada de programación eso sabe lo que me interesa ya entonces una vez que entre en esta enlace van
a irse a dole en dole hay varias maneras de instalarlo ya hay uno que si instala mediante docker
y hay otro que se está a mediante sistemas de instaladores automáticos que con los puntos
ex ya lo conocen ya la mayoría de nosotros lo vamos a instalar de manera normal y obviamente voy a
hacer una instalación de manera serializada para evitar eso ya ahora lo que quiero que hagan es lo
siguiente vayan a su microsoft si está manejando windows esto no es más igual vayan a su centralizado
como se está manejando linux igual pero como sé que la mayoría siempre utilizamos windows
voy a escribir los comandos cmed ya cmed es el símbolo del sistema es decir que la mayoría
de los sistemas en windows desde un principio ya sabemos que hay instaladores hay ventanas
cuando ustedes instalan un programa colocan siguiente siguiente siguiente siguiente y hasta
la vez nos hemos acostumbrado eso sí pero cuando utilicen símbolos de sistema ya no
utilizó ese tipo de caminos utilizó de manera mucho más decodificada y aquí me refiero de
codificada atacar directamente a lo que es el chip de la computadora así que es mejor trabajarlo
acá y hacen clica y y les va a parecer esto ya ahora hay dos formas uno pueden trabajar con esto
no se han visto alguna vez como en películas donde están casi hackeando sistemas y solamente
porque ponen esto para que les aparezca en pantalla nada más no es cuando no se simulan
algunas veces que están hackeando pero solamente es el árbol de toda la construcción de la
computadora o sea del árbol de archivos de mi sistema nada más ya pero esto nada que ver ya
en scav de nuevo voy a aplicar esto voy a hacer vuelvas a partir cmd interesan y les va a
habilitar lo que es el símbolo del sistema ya ahora para esto necesitamos netamente entender
qué es un símbolo de sistema por qué se lo aplique por qué se lo crea lo primero que
ustedes tienen que entender es que esto lo vamos a trabajar casi siempre para hacer de manera local
y se van a costumbrar no es complicado así que no se asustan y lo primero que voy a hacer es ipconfig
cuando hago y pecan y cuando ustedes tienen ven cual a que red está conectado a sus sistemas y
solamente esto conecta unos de la alámbrica quizás el de codificado sus compus y demás y
apretan enter y les va a aparecer esto en este caso estoy conectado de un medio inalámbrico con
este puerto estoy inalámbricamente mediante wifi con esta dirección de ipv4 eso se llama
este es mi puerto con el cual yo me estoy conectando a la red es ustedes pueden verlo en sus
computadoras voy a admitir alguien de muy chito eso lo pueden ver en su computador a ver hagan
clic ahí y van a ver esto y esto casi cambie y vamos a cambiarlo van a ver por qué luego les
estoy enseñando esto y luego hay máscaras de red eso luego vamos a hablarlo porque lo utiliza
y cuando lo utiliza cuando manipule mis agentes ya así que hasta ahí espero que lo hayan
tenido y apretan cls para limpiar ya vuelvas de peti y pecan fic
para volver a hacer es ahora si quieren entrar una carpeta específica en el carcader si quieren
salirse cd punto punto por ejemplo no sé yo quiero salirme de de mi sistema operativo llamado
milton ya voy a colocar cd punto punto y se salen si quiero entrar vuelvo a cd y vuelvo a escribir
milton y listo vuelven a entrar nada más esos para en realidad salir a las carpetas o a las
direcciones que yo estoy generando porque eso lo hacemos en acá de esta manera y otra manera de
manera intuitiva y de manera normal es cuando ustedes trabajan con esto tienen su carpeta
entren al disco entra en el documento y eso es lo que están haciendo pero yo estoy haciendo
mediante esto nada más ya eso ahora si volvemos a no y una vez que tenga no aquí una versión
y release generalmente las versiones lateds son las que son estables y las versiones que actualmente
se están actualizando y demás se llaman release así que voy a directamente hacer
lateds ya hacen el lateds y directamente aquí pueden obtener un montón de información que la
mayoría se prepara para qué sirves las cosas si y no nos sirven muchas de muchos es que no estamos
más que todo trabajando con odio eso lo trabajan en otro campo ya ahora si no también pueden venir
acá y pueden colocar get note y aquí pueden escoger para qué bien aquí están las diferentes
versiones que son quizás un poquito antiguitas ahora para ver yo eso puedo colocar en este caso
lo siguiente voy a borrar todo y vamos a instalar con ustedes ya ahí abranse
luego van a venir acá y van a instalarse lo siguiente a veces el cd es un poquito
tedioso el momento de instalar porque algunos los vas a hacer errores si se sale errores no
van a avisar para que hires de algunos documentos y algunas ya tengo armadito todo para que ustedes
lo ejecuten y las funciones es que cualquier tipo de errores lo que van a abrir se acá
netamente lo siguiente ya se han abierto docker no de la mayoría así que en docker
vamos a bajar van a colocar si no se aparece acá docker de acster por windows si es que
está manejando windows si no es para diferentes sistemas operativos yo voy a insertar aquí para
windows hago clic y aquí me aparece docker y aquí están las versiones tanto para 32 bit como
64 bits hagan clic acá les voy a pasar igual esto a la mensajería de
de mit listo ya los he enviado así que entren ahí ya tendrían abiertas dos dos páginas así que
vayan entrando ahí y vayan instalando esto docker de acster y se nos va a aparecer acá descargando
lo malo fíjense pesa 618 gigas yo ya lo tengo no lo voy a instalar pero necesito que ustedes lo
descarguen para que procedamos a la instalación porque mientras voy dando la clase hasta que
sea más o menos 7 supongo 7 y media ya va a estar terminado de descargar de mi es solamente lento
en internet así que va a tardar en el mío pero eso los voy esperando ya eso vayan haciendo chico
cosas luego lo siguiente en no lo vamos a instalar después que han instalado docker ya no todavía
porque voy a trabajar con unos sistemas un poquito más internos para que no tenga un
problema es a futuro porque si ya tienen no instalado algo no hay problema porque ya saben
que se pueden instalar varias versiones de note no es necesario siempre trabajar con una versión de
note ya listo una vez que tengan eso me van a avisar ya pasaremos a lo siguiente por si acaso
quizás las clases esto igual a descargar luego no te vayan descargando pero no lo ejecuten aquí
coloquen windows y ms e msi descarguen lo pero no lo van a ejecutar solamente que se descargue esos
dos necesito listo hasta ahí una vez que tengan instalados yo los voy a se los voy a subir en
en youtube cómo se ha instalación paso a paso si es que alguien no se ha olvidado o tiene
problemas y lo voy a subir en plataforma netamente por instalaciones ya sé que ese aspecto no hay
problema cuando ustedes ya lo tengan van a ejecutar no llombe o no y bien version de mí por ejemplo
22.14 ya y la actual en este caso es la 22.15 fijan soy más detrás a un poco pero yo los por
recomendación yo les diría que se instale en esta versión por recomendación porque algunas
librerías para las actuales tiene problemas así que antes de descargar el la el note por que están
descargan supongo mientras tanto docker van a entrar acá y van a buscar esa versión ya esta pueden
descargar la 12.2 o la 24.1 la 22.21 vuelvas a repetir es la mía la 22.14 algo similar pueden
hacerlo entre la 22 y la 23 son estables mejor si los recomiendo la 22.22 este que estamos viendo
acá este es la que mejor les recomiendo para para que no tengan problemas en las instalaciones
en los futuros proyectos que vamos a realizar y a por eso trabaja con docker porque a veces con docker
tratamos de a los explico que es docker antes de empezar esa partecito ya docker
generalmente nosotros cuando trabajamos con sistemas más abasas de manera local o que
leemos nosotros automatizan muchas cosas docker me sirve en este caso para trabajar con determinadas
versiones de algunos frames de algunas librerías de más por ejemplo si yo quiero fabricarme una
lla que netamente trabaje con python y que me detecte vision artificial y sistemas avanzados
en machine learning y de learning ande ve a escuchar que es machine learning y de learners ya
en ese aspecto generalmente algunas versiones por ejemplo de machine learning o de learning netamente
trabajan con python 3.10 o sea python es un tipo de frameros un tipo es un lenguaje de programación
en el cual la mayoría de los procesos que es con inteligencia artificial es la plica con python
pero lo malo de python es que cuando trabajamos por ejemplo en este caso con python la última
versión que en este caso es la la 3 15 si no me equivocó a ver vamos a entrar a python siempre
que por eso me estoy diciendo que se actualiza que siempre es un ejemplo no sé que lo hagan
solamente quiero que me entiendan cuál es la finalidad del sistema por ejemplo en python
es ahorita que versión está ya ahorita está la última no vamos a ver la 3 14 está yo tengo a ver
vamos a ver hoy de mil a 3 13 la 3 10 bien se va cargando ya entonces por ejemplo para
que me entiendan que es docker y por qué se lo trabaja en docker es lo siguiente python trabaja
con machine learning y con deep learning en su manera mayor de las libreras que son compatibles
con python a ese nivel un nivel un poquito avanzado en el o de vez entonces trabaja con
la versión 3 10 3 11 si queremos trabajar con los últimos versiones de python medio que les va a
dar un montón de errores que hay veces hay que estar parchando y después de parchar hay que estar
volviendo a descargar y que utiliza contenedores así que es muy complicado que hago entonces
docker lo engloba lo encierra a todas las versiones que son compatibles con dicha aplicación o con
dicho proyecto para que no tengan diferentes versiones y obviamente la larga podamos chocar en
versiones por ejemplo cuando yo instalo a mi entorno global una aplicación o un frame o un tipo
de código para que funcione una cosa instala una versión a la compo de manera general o sea
x siguiente siguiente siguiente y ejecutamos y listo y hemos descargado una una aplicación
digamos pero cuando aparece una nueva versión o quiero trabajar con otro tipo de aplicaciones y
justo está utilizando el mismo motor de esta aplicación justo me dice haya digamos que me
instala de whatsapp business y whatsapp normal ya el business digamos en su comillas me pide ano tú
necesitas un motor de un hp de potencia y el y el whatsapp normal me dice ano tú necesitas un motor
de tres hp de potencia que hago yo no puedo colocar dos motores a mi computadora porque solamente va
a trabajar con un motor entonces que hago como no puedo hacer eso trabajo con docker docker encierra
todo esos son contenedores o sea netamente trabajan con contenedores y esos contenedores
engloban a una determinada cantidad de procesos que trabajan con la misma versión y eso me ayuda
docker encierra todo y así que son en este caso versiones ahora hay otro punto tan no me
quiero andar mucho el ámbito programativo porque es un mundo muy muy gigantesco hay otro que podemos
trabajar se llama cobernets los cobernets también se trabaja de manera lineal con n hn
yo no lo hago porque es un lío a veces hacerlo con cobernets pero más me sirve por ejemplo
si ustedes están dedicados a negocios ahorita pero se quieren dedicar a automatizar digamos no sé
porque en el cuando hablamos de negocios estamos hablando de una palabra que casi engloba todo
y al englobar todo quizás ustedes quieren automatizar no solamente una un entorno de negocios de una
empresa netamente empresarial dedicada a bienes y raíces por ejemplo o dedicada a no sé administración
de empresas o dedicada a abogacía o ese tipo de ámbitos sino que lo podemos aplicar ámbitos
industriales porque sé que la mayoría no siempre trabajamos uno siempre llegamos al punto donde
queríamos estar sino a veces la vida nos hace un montón de marañas y terminamos en cosas que no
estamos destinados a ello pero lamentablemente a larga o bien no nos gusta o bien nos gusta y
ese es el punto entonces este ámbito de negocios no solamente los voy a enseñar un ámbito de
como la palabra dice empresarial netamente de oficina sino resuelven a nivel industrial y a nivel
de un poquito más automatizado en diferentes tipos de campos así que en base a eso voy a tratar
de manejar y es lo mismo que hacen la mayoría de los casos no eso ya se está descargando supongo
esta versión así que vamos a lo siguiente una vez que entendemos todo este aspecto
ya podemos instalar a lo malo que hoy día necesito que sí o sí su node y esté corriendo
esta no ya así que vuelvas a repetir es lo instalan ejecutan luego lo que les está
entregando acá y vamos a proceder a lo siguiente ya hasta ahí les espero mientras voy admitiendo
el mundo de sus compañeros ya una vez que lo tengan así tal cual se les va a descartar es 30.2
megabytes y es listo valeria con esta consulta para confirmar hay que descargar
el tocker para windows esto que eso ya está descargado y el node versión 22.22 exactamente
exactamente perfecto sí ya lo tengo listo una vez que tienen eso instalado procederemos a la
instalación del node voy a hacer dos maneras yo voy a hacer esto primero bueno a ócligar acá
y van a aparecer una
instalador prepara y install y los voy a hacer esto
hasta ahí ya deben estar el mío ya lo tengo pues que no me deja de ustedes solamente tienen que
coger next next next next y listo pero hay que esperar un poquito porque está mi gran ahora sí
el mío por ejemplo va a chocar con mi otra versión pero les voy a decir hasta cierto punto para que
no checa con mis versiones ya listo podemos tener varios nodes no hay problema pero mi memoria
está muriendo así que voy a tratar de hacer lo que nos decía una vez que te caen hasta acá
colocan next aceptan los términos next esto por si acaso verifiquen por ejemplo en mi caso si
voy a mi voy a dividirse en dos este es su program files a bando su este equipo van a
disculparse y buscan este program files voy a colocar minimizar esta cosa
ya hay buscan program files archivos de program en español y si no tienen nada con este nombre que
digan no gs lo instalan pero si tienen otro pueden dar otro nombre los que dominan programación
no saben ya pueden colocar el otro así que a él le aplican eso
y dice hay un mensaje de un cachiche fue pues
transcribe y a entorno es que ganas o buscan no si no hay no le meten a ver enter enter enter
siguiente siguiente está el en mí por ejemplo dividen varios segmentos y que no hay problema con
el mío hayan siguiente de esto todo está bien algunos podemos desinstalarlo pero no
manténlo así por defecto y instale next ya next next automáticamente esto coloquen
no hay coloque antes de esto chocolate van a necesitar de no lo cliquen van a tener
problemas y no hay dejenlo sin clicarlo y next y por último instale
ya que tal patricia el otro es docker vas a escribir si tienes windows lo colocas
solamente docker desktop y te va a aparecer para mac para linux pero si es para windows
directamente los específicos por ejemplo ya acá
voy a colocar docker for windows nada más aquí está aquí miren
dice docker desktop aquí está los diferentes sistemas operativos ya
en este caso de mí es a med y lo instalo en versión m de 64 listo les estoy pasando los
links a los que acaban de entrar ya y lo voy a colocar también en la plataforma
ya de mencachito
el docker y el no sí exacto docker primer
ya una vez que lo tengan hasta ahí me avisan ya y esto tienen que clicar igual en instalar y
que lo va a instalar y lo voy a cancelar porque yo lo tengo porque les va a pedir permitir que
está aplicarse el tenia en su tienda la pelada
yo que está voy a cerrar esta parte de los videos
con el mismo que voy a hacer en nadie
cuando tome todo con todo sec a todo con el
como se habla solo y ya
listo ya entonces coloquen finish y listo
y ya está luego bueno una vez que hagan eso
instale no van a colocar no guion de y les tiene que parecer esta versión que están
instalando seguramente se va a pasar a 22.22.22 o 22.22 hasta ahí traten de llegarlo
ya les he enviado por secas igual al chavos en las de no y docker
ya esto lo voy a cerrar
ya
cuando ya estén hasta el no me avisan levantan la mano los que ya están luego ya para proceder
a lo siguiente que vamos a hacer mientras tanto tienes están
en el piso de la mano
ya no se sorprendan si no lo terminamos en unas seis clases a siete clases
vamos a hacer más aplicaciones en las manos
ya están levantando manos pueden haber no hay problema
en un pequeño problema no pero si el toque me sale un aviso
y que te dice por razones de seguridad la dirección de c program data tocker
de estado probablemente must be owned by el efeit aconte necesita permisos de
asignar el permiso debe haber dos opciones hay que desapareciendo
y le doy este asignar como
la administradora y si directamente como el
administrador y a eso y no por alguna razón me sale puedes compartir tu pantalla
sino que ya porfa que comparte es para que te ayude y estar así
y
ya
ya andate a la carpeta donde lo has descargado
y esa parte
y a clic derecho ejecutar como administrador con el color y
y ahora esperamos
y ahora si es un mes más implication.
yaonse los siguientes aceptaron amas no se deja de compartirων
les voy a explicar ha de este governments
no masanto
esto
Ya. Hay dos problemas con Docker generalmente que lo trabajan con ese tipo de muy tutoria,
silenciar, arribar, listo.
Ya, tu compañero por ejemplo ya está dando una solución, tu compañero dice se puede eliminar
Docker en ese programa exactamente. Hay dos maneras, una para que eliminas de manera directa
de tu programa acá.
Ahora entra a tu, este equipo, entra acá.
Hay tres formas, te voy a enseñar, las tres formas están acá.
Ya uno es que aquí busca Docker y elimina lo de esa carpeta. Busca lo Docker acá en tu discosé.
Otra manera es esta, si es que te sigue dando, hay tres tipos de sistemas, ¿sí?
El que les acabo de enviar este de acá, es el que realmente vamos a trabajar con este para que no tengan problemas.
Hay versiones medio raras ahí.
Ya aquí, aquí por ejemplo, aquí dice InstaLocker for desktop, este pueden elegir.
Ya, esto lo instalan y diste para Windows y este es el que es más estable en SystemiT.
Ya, esto lo han descargado si no momento ustedes.
O pueden trabajar con Microsoft Store, con cada de los dos es que les sigue dando errores.
Pero intenta primero con ese y me avises, eliminando eso, la carpeta si los he encontrado.
Ya, y lo que has descargado, lo vuelves a ejecutar, luego lo vamos a eliminar esa parte.
Ya, pero ahorita lo que me interesa es no, si tienen varios problemas igual voy a subir algunos SystemiT.
Ahora, si hay uno que se guarda acá, ahora el otro es esto, si no encuentras en ahí, puedes venir acá.
Colocas acá, ver y aquí vas a colocar mostrar elementos ocultos.
Esto lo vas a clicar, porque vamos a entrar a una carpeta donde generalmente no aparecen algunos computadores.
Ya, así que colocas ahí elementos ocultos, cliqueas, lo encuentras acá y vas a buscar lo siguiente.
En este caso, puedes irte a usuarios o puedes buscar aquí program data.
Y ahí vas a buscar igual el Docker. Aquí está, ves, ahí aparece una carpeta medio que borrosa, eso es porque estaba oculto.
Ahí entras y aquí vas a buscar lo que es Docker, ahí también puedes borrarlo lo que es.
Aquí mira, aquí dice Docker Desktop, eso lo borras y lo vuelves a instalar.
Esta parte si te borrarlo y listo, lo vuelves a ejecutar.
Ya, ahora sí. Mientras tanto, los que hayan instalado Notes, y esto.
Levanta en la mano para proceder a lo siguiente. Obviamente no voy a trabajar con Docker, así que hay tiempo para eso.
Levanta en la mano los que ya tienen instalado Notes para, lo sé, o los voy a seguir esperando los demás, no hay problema.
Y acá Dalia tiene, quién más lo tiene. Note, solamente Note.
Ya, así los espero.
Ya, faltan muchos, así que los doy tiempo y te achiques para que vayan instalando Notes.
Mientras les voy a estar mostrando qué podemos hacer con Docker.
Ya. Mientras tanto, bien va instalando. Es liviano, así que no van a tardar mucho.
Patricia, ya lo tienes o es una consulta?
Ya lo tengo.
Ya, super.
Alguien más.
Cuántos somos? 22.
Bueno, quitando a mi adulto somos 20.
De los 20 tendrán que estar mínimo 11 ya con la instalación para proceder.
2 ya llega. Si alguien más lo tiene, super.
Ya van a estar haciendo los pintos.
Mamá, los voy esperando.
Para la siguiente clase, que es el jueves, van a crear ustedes un Word.
Donde esté un negocio en el cual ustedes van a trabajar.
Pongo en lo que yo voy a hacer papas fritas.
Pero tengo pedidos, tengo mis proveedores, tengo mis cursales.
Todos se vayan armándose. Todavía no lo voy a aplicar, pero ustedes vayan armando su negocio netamente.
Porque es la larga, vamos a automatizarlo.
Ya, así que para eso pueden trabajar de dos maneras.
Pueden trabajar con Marta o pueden trabajar con codificación latex.
Yo trabajo más con Marta para hacer ese tipo de sistemas.
O pueden trabajar con wearables.
Ahora os vemos que son wearables.
Y con Warpets.
También pueden hacerlo con Figma, si desean.
O pueden hacerlo con cualquier tipo de plataformas.
A ver, por ejemplo, yo necesito lo así para la siguiente clase lo siguiente.
Os voy a mostrar algunos...
...erramientes para que ustedes vayan aplicándolo a sus proyectos.
Está bien lento esto.
Figma en este caso trabaja para en tonos.
Pueden hacerlo con IA o pueden trabajar de manera legal.
O sea, sin IA.
Lo que yo les recomiendo es que...
Bueno, si fueran de programación les diría que no sean muy abusivos con la IA, pero no somos de programación.
Así que no las veis, si quieres.
Ya, así que podemos trabajar con diferentes tipos de sistemas.
Para hacerlo rápido, obviamente se puede, pero...
Este es Figma.
Hace una interfaz de cómo puede ser mi automatización.
No solamente automatización, podemos trabajar también con modelo de negocios.
Pueden hacerlo con sistemas Kamba, pueden hacerlo con Figma, pueden ser por Traybase o Pimp Pensil.
Pueden trabajar.
Yo trabajaba con Pensil.
Si quieren trabajar con Pensil es bonito.
Pero no, no tenía.
Es lo que no les va a favorecer algún aspecto para hacerlo rápido.
Pero Pensil pueden trabajar.
A ver, realmente me voy a trabajar con Pensil.
Ay, perdón.
Aper Pensil.
Ya, este es Pensil Project.
Esto puede ser click.
Hay dos.
Con la un InchCode pueden trabajarlo.
Pueden descargarse de Pensil.
Y se maneja un montón de cosas.
Aquí espero más que todo es una automatización, más que todo para entre los gráficos.
Ya.
O sea, si quieren ustedes hacer un modelo de negocio y un modelo de negocio que pueden automatizar para sus clientes,
algo que sea trayente y algo que sea bastante interesante pueden aplicar Pensil.
Se puede descargar y lo trabajan con Cloud Code, o Bizcode.
Pero generalmente esto trabaja con Skills.
Máximo tienen tres Skills.
Tienen que si comprarse.
Pero no les recomiendo si es que no tienen eso.
Ahora, hay otro que vamos a trabajar con este app.
No, todo se los voy a pasar, así que no hay problema.
Igual lo hace.
Quien es la agenda, es sistematizado.
O sea, esto ya es algo más...
dedicado a empresas.
Pero...
se puede generar un Pensil propio.
Luego los vindica cómo hacer eso.
Pero es bastante interesante.
Ya.
Hasta ahí.
Cuánto se lo tienen, chico?
Para continuar.
De a dos.
Necesito once.
Once y avanzamos.
Y no hay once.
Me voy a quedar.
O les obligo a que prendamos.
Creo que los voy a obligar.
Pero háganlo esa parte, chicos.
Once, ya tenemos tres.
Cuatro, tres tenemos.
Faltan.
Por favor.
Y si quizá mientras mi compañero me han terminado,
le podría compartir pantalla para que me ayude.
No me sale la opción para ver esos archivos ocultos.
Ya, a ver, ahora sí, compartilo.
Gracias.
Visto.
Vale.
Estoy aquí en el Colocal C.
¿No?
Activo la parte de Berno, ¿verdad?
Eso es lo que quieran encontrar.
Ya.
Ahí está.
Allá arriba está.
Allá arriba está eso, ¿verdad?
Abajo dice mostrar.
Ahí dice, ahí abajo.
Bajate con tu mouse.
Te estoy listo.
En el que te pones.
No, no, no.
Yo voy a ponerle la parte de Berno.
No me puedo, yo no voy a ponerle la parte de Berno.
Es que yo no me he puesto el pared.
ahí abajo bajate con tu mouse te está tapando creo que así debe decir ver archivos ocultos
es a clic ahora entró a ir a discos para andarte a programa hay de ver a parcer ahí dice program
data dice más abajo program es ahora hay blusca ahí dice tocker eso por raro
list ahora si vuelve a ejecutar tu instalador
y ahora si te abres todo eso
sigue te da
ya ahora vas a hacer lo siguiente de nuevo es lo mismo pero con
con ejecutar como administrador
y si no vamos a hacerlo más fregado para para completar esa parte
ya
si no te da eso vamos a hacer otro otro sistema
si creo que ya ya listo hay esperanza un cacho luego
no hay pleno ya gracias y esto no te preocupes
ya cuántos ya tenemos
tres chicos tres cuatro necesito once once quien da más once necesito
cinco
seis
y solamente si se puede instalar los dos que si ya tienen los 600 megas descargados no hay
problema ya y a mí no me permite descargarlo por el tema de espacio tengo que
eliminar los archivos y pierda mi computadora pero el no ya ya puede descargar no hay problema
no hay problema
pero si no vas a estar luego un docker así que desespero mientras tanto igual para instalar esa parte
ya lo siguiente a ver yo voy a abrir mi docker nuestro
les va a decir que hablite un shock cuando va a instalar y olito y así así así esto y listo
ya de un cachito voy a abrir mi docker bueno docker eso sí listo eso es docker
bueno es si va a dar al principio para evitar y de un literar
ya ahora si pueden pueden crearse usuarios pero usuario contraseña que crearse posteriormente
pero también podemos trabajar de manera directa así que no hay problema
hay perdón gracias gracias por suerte se agravan así que no hay problema
ya listo
vamos a hacer lo siguiente no sé si les parece lo siguiente chocos les parece que grave algunas
que tengan cosas bastante pesadas y una vez que lo vean ustedes en la siguiente clase
ya van a tener hechito o se ya van a estar listos como para proceder así no perdemos un poco de
tiempo ya eso voy a tratar de ser con ustedes para no perder tiempo y en descargas y así
directamente me consultan en los nuestros poncia si nos vamos a perder tiempo y
hasta que tenemos suficiente tiempo así de manera directa les puedo hablar que docker digo
en h&m y en tres clases a cuatro se termina pero sí es que tenemos todo hecho y derecho pero si
es que avanzamos cosas más específicas con agentes con sistemas avanzados pongan las que hasta
18 16 clases así que alcanzamos incluso nos va a sobrar unos 4 5 clases y no habría problema ya
hace siempre tardó el principio por eso un poquito mucho depende de sus computadoras también
por ejemplo la mía si entro acá voy a configuraciones
y van a ver mi windows es bastante básico igual no tiene muchas aplicaciones pero
bueno si tengo pero si igual me genera problemas
y mientras tanto por ejemplo mira en la mía esto no más tiene
almacenamiento medio tera 2 llegas de 16 y eso es todo
para que no les genere problemas a partir de 8 de ram normal es córrepe si es menor obviamente no
va a tener mucho y ahora si no no es que ha ido eso vale a lo siguiente y nos vamos a esperándolo
porque solamente cuántos personas hay 7
bien acá van a escribir n8n ingresan n8n van a ir a hay 4 flow automitrizio para
los voy a pasar ese link ya no bajen las manos los que ya tienen para estar contando ya si tienen
todas consultas igual me hablan o es ya vayan entrando en n8n punto y o hayo estoy enviando
a la plataforma y también los estoy mandando a su
a su grupo de whatsapp
y pueden entrar con great start for free o directamente sin ya hay entrón y pueden crecer
usuario ya hay van a esperar un poco y aquí el mío ya está creado pero en este caso pueden
empezar con acá o si está por cría y ahí pueden colocar su compañía no se yo me llamo
bosón digamos bosón y ahí buena eso todavía pueden crear pero aquí van a colocar su gmail que
utilizan o un gmail alterno pueden colocar dependen de ustedes y ahí voy a desaltar y en el arterno
a ver vamos desaltar gmail
y
ahí va encarando semillas tanto
para que las clases sean un poquito didacticasas algunas clases donde si les voy a preguntar cosas
ya hay ingres en el gmail y van a observar en su bosón de entrada en su bosón de su gmail les va a llegar la
el código en mi caso
ya me he llegado me dice n8n.ya vamos a verificar eso y lo voy a copiar 567133 lo copio o lo puedo
clicar ahí depende de ustedes ya y nada más ahora voy a minimizar esto y aquí lo voy a colocar
ya tengo que crear varios de acá así que quizás no me permite porque ya tengo
lo estoy indicando cómo tienen que hacer
ojo chicos esto que se están creando acá no se olviden
guardenlo si o si ya para no estar cada vez volviendo a instalar o volver a crear sus controceñas
guardenlo porque lo mismo que estoy creándome acá con lo mismo vamos a entrar a nuestro
n8n que está nuestro computador y esa partecita por favor no se olviden eso vayan haciendo
y vamos a hacer lo siguiente como cada clase tiene que ser práctica y tiene que ser más que todo
participativa vamos a hacer esto van a ver un word
y eso me pueden enviar hasta el día de mañana o sea siempre va a ver ese rango
si tenemos la clase mañana me tienen que enviar si o si en su word van a colocar la siguiente
didáctica van a colocar en este caso van a trabajar así margen estrechos voy a pasar la plantilla no hay
problema van a colocar clase 1 van a colocar n8n bueno en este caso si voy a pasar la plantilla
ya voy a colocar curso de automatización
n8n vamos a colocar en este caso en bajada o los estados de cen a bajar no colocar nombre su nombre de
ustedes y apellido completos van a colocar la fecha del día en cuál se ha llevado la clase y me van
a colocar en este caso también la parte de
hasta y por mientras tanto ya le van a colocar clase 1 voy a hacerlo así para que sea algo más
participativo y que realmente trabajen porque hay veces por experiencia les digo
que no trabajan algunos alumnos y que prefiero hacerlo así para que todos se damos participativos y
ya una vez que tengamos eso voy a pasar la plantilla bonito más bonito que lo que estoy haciendo
y aquí van a colocar clase 1 dentro de la clase 1 van a colocar pasos paso 1 instalando
no y paso 2 instalando docker
y así paso 3 no sé qué vendrá paso 3 creando en este caso usuario n8n
8n que me diga online listo y ahí me tienen que sacar lo siguiente digamos y instalado no es
necesario que me instalen todo el proceso contar que ustedes me saquen el screen de pantalla porque
esto es el nombre de su computadora así yo voy a poder reconocer si realmente su compa
porque hay veces mis alumnos me hacen esa esa maraña porque me mandan el mismo screen y como
y no se dan cuenta que me están enviando de la misma computadora no todos los computadores
llaman lo mismo no sé qué es lo que instalando docker me tienen que enviar por ejemplo y ahí
hasta instalado esto pues lo voy a colocar así una una screen
y listo y ahí tiene que estar todo y todos ustedes y listo lo ven y misa le lo pegan ahí
y hasta y entonces así vamos a tratar de armar las clases para que para que ustedes también tengan
uno el vídeo y uno como como si los pasos que han hecho ya y cómo están trabajando para que no se
olviden tampoco ustedes y luego paso número tres pues colocan lo que estoy haciendo ahorita no
que es esto creado y listo ahí colocamos y eso también me tienen que enviar de manera
así tal cual ahora pregunta para todos ustedes cuánto tiempo quieren para esto
un día mañana les doy hasta el otro un día antes de la siguiente clase cuando lo quieren
porque mejor si lo hacen hoy mismo para que no se olviden ya eso eso quedaremos entre nosotros
porque si no es nada vamos a avanzar ya eso giren chicos hasta mañana les doy 24 horas 48 horas 72
horas o cuánto desean ustedes de tiempo para subir sus trabajos de cada clase posterior
y ya que fuera un bien antes de la siguiente clase ya que tengo que seleccionar archivos de mi laptop
ya ya súper entonces va a ser siempre 24 horas antes de la siguiente clase listo ya no hay problema
chicos eso quedamos para que todos trabajemos de lo mismo manera ya hasta ahí lo tienen ahora
vamos a entrar a la segunda parte ya voy a hacer ahora este encajo porque ya he creado otros sistemas
y
así una vez que lo creen ahí e vayan ingresando esos enhechos de manera online creando sus
passwords y cuántas años esto no necesitan así que voy a colocar por ejemplo basón
y pasos no son inventaron
o lo que no pasó el que no se lo vieron por su casa
y aquí voy a colocarnos
ya eso no es lo que no es lo que más cositas acá no hay problema ya así que me olvida por
ejemplo que puesto bien y lo que tengan el mismo que yo listo y ya les va a crear esperan le colocan
gracias ya y vamos a colocar lo siguiente
exactamente se está grabando las clases no se preocupan ya ahora en este caso van a colocar
acá solamente for me o por mi para mí ok luego colocan para que no para que les para que un
cachito le engañemos en el 8 n para que me dé algunos prompts más directos vamos a colocar
aquí
marketing les soporta ok van a colocar y aquí van a colocar siempre ojo siempre creen aquí con su
link en cuando crean en el 8 n con su link en inglés de algunos beneficios más que podemos
hacerlo de manera online ya no de manera local así que mejor si lo meten su link y
ya bien en este caso pueden trabajar con su con quién más colaborar ya en este caso
tu
usado
y esto ya está pueden invitar para que para proyectos donde os olviden necesitan vacabos o
tienen trabajar en grupo con el 8 n no solamente una persona que hay en el reservario o sistemas
pero que pueden hacer si nos pueden colocar script no hay problema ya y ya está ahora empezamos de
manera automática y las ahorita la interfaz de noche ahí esperamos un poco y listo lo van a tener
ya mientras tanto de mi cachito chocó
los
en estos 14 días podemos hacer un montón de
cositas aquí así que la siguiente clase y voy a hacer algunos videos trabajando de esto y a ver si
lo implementan rápidamente para tener más más extensión del trabajo o lo pueden en este caso
también comprar si lo quieren comprar en el 8 n hay otros sistemas ya actuales les comento
yo les recomiendo así no como docente sino como un colaborador más o como si estuviéramos
trabajando en la misma compañía yo les recomiendo que en el 8 n lo trabajen de manera local
si van a hacer negocios o se van a tener un servidor central porque ya hay otros sistemas
avanzados que superan en 8 n y es mucho más rápido pero si exige un poquito más de conocimientos
en programación ya pero es casi lo mismo pero el otro me ofrece incluso inteligencia artificial es
que trabajar con 17 18 inteligencia artificial incorporadas y trabajar con automatización es
no solamente en ámbitos empresariales sino en ámbitos industriales y otro trabajo con
schrinberg y también hay con python divit esos son dos sistemas potentes para sistemas de python
avanzado y se puede hacer más cosas ya pero en 8 n está bien para para procesos más que no son
de netamente del problema así para aquí podemos ver cuáles son los costos ya y esto ojo es por mes
creo que hay algunas ofertas más que todo para
anuales ya pero vamos a empezar obviamente con fría nada más así que hasta ahí
una vez que lo tengan hasta acá podemos hacer algunas aplicaciones bastante interesantes a ver
si esperemos hasta ahí
y a por ejemplo acá cuando trabajamos con el spa y se va a hacer vamos a trabajar con
estadísticos también vamos a colocar randwith demo start for scratch listos en click ahí
esperamos un poquito
ahí se van a ejecutar algunos puntos ya esto por ejemplo es una interfaz ya hecha
para ver cómo trabajamos con gmail o como de los de open e i ahora en este caso
si ustedes quieren trabajar como de los de open e i o sea no solamente de las repeticiones de cloud
pueden comprarse scales o tokens un millón de tokens creo que no se cuenta en cloud no utilizo
mucho cloud más que tu tienes otros softwares pido tus días pero mientras ustedes pueden
trabajar con cuáles desea mucho más acerquible ya así que si entramos a open e i vamos a ver cuál
es los costos más o menos para que podamos trabajar en este aspecto ya hay también con otro tipo de
sistemas pero vamos a ver ahora sí vamos a también descarar lo siguiente antes de continuar voy a
venirme ahora a oyama y ahí vamos a ver qué podemos hacer cosas más interesantes después de las
clases de n8n pero que si aquí lo tengan directamente instalado para que habían como se trabaja también
con otros agentes de ida entra en a oyama les voy a pasar ahorita el enlace igual y luego
explicar algunas cositas de ica es necesario que lo entieman y que lo apliquen si es que están
si para vosotros de manera local pero todavía no es aparte ya que le faltan muchos que vayan
instalando tokens pero voy a hacerlo en ambos ámbitos ya los estoy haciendo de manera online
para aprovechar algunos puntos más que vamos a tratar pero luego vamos a trabajar de manera local
también directamente voy a trabajar en primera parte con manera local y les explico un poquito
esta parte o llama más que todo trabaja como un intérprete de lo que va a ser los modelos de ida
o modelos de inteligencia artificial ya creadas por ejemplo la última de chad y pt 5.2 está
alrededor de 34 billones de entrenamientos internos que tiene pero como pueden entender eso más o
menos si dentro y ahorita models que moda hay a modelos entrenados por ejemplo no sé si ahora
entreno a un chimpanze para que me pase por ejemplo no sé una roca siempre que me que a mí me
pase la roca cada mañana ten que entrenarle ese entrenamiento dura no solamente un día dos días
tres días puede durar incluso meses o años para que haga eso esto es lo mismo pero aquí
ha sido entrenado con un montón de datos para que este modelo ya me pueda responder si es que
ciertas características ahora si cómo nos vamos a dar que es cómo nos vamos a dar cuenta que su
modelo avanzado o no avanzado o que su modelo mucho más de bajo escala o bajo nivel en este caso
trabajamos con este tipo de simulito ya los que tienen tres b 4 b son los más básicos y los que
menos capacidades de memoria les va a exigir ya pero hay modelos que trabajan con 277 billones o
sabés y hay miren aquí 122 b hay otros modelos que trabajan con más incluso pero aquí generalmente
1 de 30 a 43 por ejemplo miren este es sumamente liviano es un modelo de dipstick
ya pueden bajarlo a ver si entramos a dipstick acá lo malo de esto es que ves es un poco lento o no
me ofrece mucho rango de de en este caso de respuesta pero si es interesante como responde pero miren
pesa 6.7 gigabytes lo pueden trabajar con esto de manera interna ya pero si tienen una computadora
que es pro o sea muy avanzada tanto en rango sus gpo pueden instalarse una que tenga estas
características como la de extra que es la 123 b ya o hay la o mart que haya parecido otra la gm 4.9
que es una buena y pueden trabajar ahí de manera interna sin hacer esquías de las demás de
copenco comprar cosas evitamos por ejemplo esto es muy bueno pues esta se le asemeja a la chacha y
pt 4.5 y tiene 2 2 2 2 255 b pueden trabajar pero fíjense cuánto es su capacidad que necesitan
143 gigas les va a exigir de escagar eso y no nos convierte pueden trabajar como de los sí
a preguntar cuál que tal este estos modelos son como podría decir yas o en sí como por
secuencias de actividades específicas son en sí yas y aquí por ejemplo crees
el nombre de este gigante sobre esta este estas yas son de libre acceso a la que uno puede descargar
sí son de libre acceso directamente a cuándo es que lo descargar sin que se pueda centrar su
carne y modificar ellos se puede manipular incluso generalmente por ejemplo la empresa no se
hacía en escuchar de blu origin de jeff esos conocen a jeff esos de blu origin por ejemplo uno
de sus hackers ha intentado hackear los sistemas de aniquilación que tenía la nasa y parte de
el oler en los más y lo ha hecho gracias a lo que es la clonación que ha descargado la parte de
que se llama esta empresa la se me fue un hombre si te preocupa en la la antítesis de opinión
ahí hay se me fue el nombre y la otra empresa brutal en la inteligencia artificiales pero esa
contratado jeff besos y con eso ha podido controlar los cohetes en control avanzada y control
independiente para sus cohetes y con eso se han creado ya sistemas de guerras frías a nivel
espacial eso maneja más o menos y se puede hacer eso porque ahorita justamente ayer se ha liberado
cuatro yas potentes para la parte de apenía y eso ahorita os voy a mostrar que se me ha ido el nombre
pero ahorita se me va a acordar y les voy a mostrar esto por si se puede manipular si se
puede echar su carner pueden ver un montón de cosas ahí en manera encriptada y si se puede
trabajar incluso con sus propios modelos por ejemplo yo independientemente creo yas para
sistemas robóticos para mis clientes por ejemplo yo utilizo digamos ahorita yo fabrico prótesis
para los diferentes hospitales y les meto estas yas para que puedan tener una latencia de la red y
latencia de sus sistemas de control de manera estable y para no depender de ellas en la nube y
eso yo hago pero en la parte de hardware no tanto en software pero si utilizo estas yas ya ahora
una que es bastante liviana es la mistra es la más liviana y que tiene un nivel aceptable de
cognitividad esto que es de 7b y no está empezada miren esa 4.4 yas y esto creo que lo pueden tener
todos yo les recomiendo esto para hacer pruebas básicas y pruebas no tan básicas o si tiene nivel
tiene nivel pero es la más 7b es es es considerado esto eso descarguense los veas los veas subir un
documento muy aparte donde está paso a paso cómo tienen que instalar esto si lo hacen súper esto
por si acaso lo que los estoy mostrando se puede trabajar con n hn pero en este curso es como vamos
a trabajar de manera aditiva no de manera que tengamos que seguir con el penso que ya está
definido si es que nos alcanza algo más de tiempo y lo voy a implementar pero si o si hay
algunas veces algunas clases si siempre lo implemento así que no se hagan no se asusten
seis veces voy a hacer cosas fuera de la clase que van a ser más interesantes pero con el hn
fuera del penso así que si lo tienen y al listito no hay más chicos y lo pueden trabajar por
ejemplo miran acá yo voy a ejecutar mi mi oleada
ahí está ejecutando
esta parte voy a minimizar el lenguaje
y ahora les voy a mostrar esa parte
ya me pueden trabajar y pueden ver hablar incluso o llama y n hn se le puede implementar con
alexa cuando solamente le hablas ya te puede indicar que está pasando que el coro te ha llegado
quien te ha depositado cuál es tu factibilidad de tu negocio en cierto plazo y todo suceso
es un mundo muy interesante ya eso es un chico que os creo que ya se van a cumplir el tiempo
ya es casi 8 la clase quedaremos en lo siguiente y hasta la siguiente clase necesito hasta acá sus
modelos de sus instalaciones en su world suck in the screen los voy a enviar después de la clase
el código de classroom les voy a mandar el código del drive y los voy a enviar el código de sus
kits ya así que en base se pueden clonar subir sus documentaciones ahí va a estar las grabaciones
que voy a subir ahí va a estar todo de manera ordenada cualquier consulta escríbame mediante
el inbox y la clase también lo voy a colocar en el en el clavo todo va a estar ahí ya así que no se
preocupa voy a detener la grabación del encuchito